now we've got a little bit of breaking
news to bring you because our political
editor Beth Rigby has just heard that
Jacob Reese MOG has resigned from
government of course a close Ally of
both Boris Johnson and Liz truss his
letter uh Beth here's has been delivered
to the new prime minister
well let's bring in Jay Pike shall we is
it a case of jumping before he was
pushed do you think it certainly is
Sophie we know that Jacob Reese smog
called Richie sunak over the summer
during that leadership race a socialist
Chancellor he said he wouldn't serve in
a sunac Administration and of course he
realizes the chances of being given a
senior job are close to zero he of
course though is a high profile
parliamentarian to the right of his
party former ERG chair high profile
partly because of his sort of
Personality his style it's sort of it's
not eccentric in contrast to many of his
colleagues but he has been a very
willing spokesperson for Boris Johnson
and his trust not necessarily some would
argue to their own benefit I think we've
spoken about what role is trust plays on
the back benches Jacob Reese smog could
also potentially be a difficult a person
to move to the back benches even though
the fact he hasn't got a top job is
pretty inevitable today